MALE SPEAKER: Hello, and
welcome to the Google Tech Talk.
Today it's my pleasure
to announce and introduce
Nikunj Oza from
NASA Ames Lab where
he is the leader in the
Data Sciences Group,
and he's going to talk about
anomaly detection in aviation
systems.
NIKUNJ OZA: So I'll
first give a little bit
of a general overview of
what sorts of problems
are of interest to NASA.
And then I'll dive
a little bit more
into the problem of
detecting anomalies
in aircraft trajectory,
specifically,
which is one recent focus area.
I'll show just where data
mining fits in, at least what
we've thought of so far, and
what we've been implementing,
and what kind of data we
get, algorithms, results.
And then I'll give a brief
overview of some other work
that we're also doing in
the Data Sciences Group.
And then also a
little description
of how you all can get
involved in our efforts.
So in general, NASA is aimed at
problems in aeronautics, earth
science, space science,
and space exploration.
And so the Data
Science Group looks
at how data mining
algorithms can
be applied to these
different areas.
So for example,
within aeronautics,
a big focus of ours has
been aviation safety.
For example, identifying
previously unknown anomalies
that are of some
operational significance,
that have a safety concern.
We are also doing
some other work
in aeronautics such
as using machine
learning for surrogate modeling.
And also we are doing
right now some text
mining as well-- that's
actually an effort that's
been going for quite a while.
Then as far as applications
to earth science,
one area is anomaly detection.
There are numerous data
sources, whether it's
space borne, ground-based,
airborne, where
you expect there to be
certain relationships
between the measurements
that are taken.
And we spent some effort
looking for anomalies
in those relationships
because those
may be indicative of some
unusual phenomenon taking
place.
Also some filling
in missing data.
So this is the problem
of when NASA develops
new instruments that are
deployed that typically collect
data in greater number of
bands, of spectral bands
than the older instruments.
Then we use machine learning
to actually kind of fill
in what those
measurements would have
been for some of the
earlier instruments,
given that those early ones did
not have the bands available.
And of course,
those are estimates,
but we can at least
use those to figure out
some interesting
phenomenon from the past.
And then we've also done some
work in space exploration,
mostly in the area of
systems health management
looking for anomalies
in systems operations.
Now, more specifically
for anomaly detection
within aviation, the
current way that it is done,
whether at the
carrier level or at,
say, within air
traffic control, is
that they use what are called
exceedance-based methods.
So there are certain
anomalies that they
know about that
typically are conditions
over two to three variables.
You can think of them
as maybe being rules.
So I give one example
here that during landing
when the altitude
reaches 1,000 feet
they would like that
the aircraft is not
traveling faster than 250
nautical miles per hour.
If it is, that is sometimes
referred to as a speed
high exceedance.
So for that particular
flight, the system
will essentially
check a box saying
that exceedance
has been violated.
They do typically also have
a severity of exceedance
that they indicate.
And then most flights will
have at least a few exceedances
but they're not such a big deal.
Then they have a
system, it's often
called the morning report, where
it'll show these exceedances
for all the flights
of the previous day.
And so they'll look at it.
They'll see, OK,
most flights have
some number of anomalies
of some exceedances.
But if they see a few flights
that have many more exceedances
than that, or a lot of really
high severity exceedances,
and they have not
received a safety report
from the pilot or some
other member of the crew,
then the carrier will
go and talk to the crew
and ask OK, what
happened with that.
Now, this is great
for identifying
what they're looking for.
So, for example, for the
speed high exceedance,
if you want to find it, you
have this rule, it'll find it.
So it certainly has a
low false positive rate
because it tells
you what you want.
But it has a high false
negative, or misdetection rate,
because almost by definition it
cannot find what you don't tell
it to look for.
So we decided to come at it
from the opposite perspective
of saying let's use data-driven
methods to discover anomalies
just by looking at the
statistical properties
of the data, finding which
data points do not fit.
Let's say they're far
away in some sense,
or they are of low
probability in some sense
where I need to, of course,
define what "some sense" means.
And I'll be getting into
that a little bit later.
The methods we've
explored so far
don't require background
knowledge on the anomalies.
So in some ways that's good.
You're not entering with
preconceived knowledge
about the system is operating.
You're just telling the data
to kind of speak for itself.
And in this way, it's
complementary to existing
methods.
It has a low false
negative rate.
We assume that data that appears
normal through our methods
probably represents normal
operation, because overall,
the aviation system we've
seen is a very safe system.
And we figured that
the data points
that are identified as
anomalous, yeah, they may have
some false positives because
there may be data glitches,
but we figure that new problems
that people don't really
know about are likely to be
in that set of anomalies,
the statistical anomalies.
And the pipeline that
we have used actually
is what I describe
in the last bullet
there where we run these
data driven methods,
identify some anomalies.
Yes, some of them turn
out to be false positive,
but there are some
useful insights that
can be drawn from
that and they can
be used to modify the
exceedance-based methods.
And in fact, we do have
partnerships with some carriers
where they have,
in fact, told us
that based on the
insights of our algorithms
they have made modifications to
their daily exceedance review.
And so then that ends up being
something operational then.
So really the key
for us really is
mining this heterogeneous data
because the national airspace
and even the operation
of a single aircraft
is described by variables of
many different modalities.
So you have discrete
variables-- these
may represent say like
auto pilot modes, switches
that pilots may press during
the operation of a flight.
There's continuous data--
things like altitude, air speed,
and others.
Then there is what
I call networks.
Basically they're radar data.
They represent trajectories
that the aircraft travel in
and that's where you can have
the possibility of interactions
between aircrafts, so
there is, of course,
the need to maintain certain
separation between aircraft.
So that's a key way in which
the aircraft behavior ends up
depending on the behavior
of other aircraft.
And then we also do have text.
So the various carriers do
have internal safety reporting
systems.
And NASA itself also runs
what's called the aviation
safety reporting
system or ASRS--
it's actually
administered out of Ames.
And after any commercial
flight, any member
of the crew or even
a passenger, if you
feel that there's something
irregular, a safety
concern that took
place on the flight,
that person can actually
submit a report,
and then the report does go
through some redaction process.
Some subset of the reports
after being redacted
are actually released
to the public.
And FAA also keep
track of these reports,
find out about any new problems
that seem to be popping up,
and we'll work to
investigate what changes
can be made to the
national airspace
based on new problems
that are reported.
So we would really like
to utilize and analyze
all of that data at once to find
any new or emerging problems.
So I'll go a little more
into the specific problem
of detecting anomalies
in aircraft trajectories
at this point.
So there is a system run by
FAA called the Performance Data
Analysis and Reporting
System or PDARS.
It gathers data from
the US airspace,
so the trajectory
of every flight
is recorded as
part of the system.
And it takes care of
data quality issues, so
in particular, for
PDARS there are actually
three different sources of
trajectories that are used,
and they are actually
fused in order
to create fly tracks that
are more accurate than what
each one would otherwise.
That's where the merging
process that I mentioned here
takes place.
And then part of PDARS, some
analysis and visualization
is also done.
And then this data is
also made available
to certain other
key partners who
also are interested
in this area.
There is the desire expressed at
different levels of government
to improve the
analysis capabilities.
There's a realization that there
is this vast amount of data.
We really need to do more
to study that data in order
to find new problems.
That's the upshot of
what's being mentioned
by, in this case, GAO and the
Office of Inspector General.
So that's part of what prompted
our little effort, which
I'll talk about at this point.
So for us, we went into this
really wanting to-- we thought
that our data-driven methods
could identify anomalies
within radar track
data, and so we ended up
investigating that
in two phases.
So there was one phase that took
place in 2012 to 2013 where we
looked at two years' worth
of data involving LAX.
In that case, it was looking
primarily at landings at LAX.
As part of that
effort we ended up
identifying 15 operationally
significant anomalies
where originally those
were unknown, actually.
So it was our
algorithms that actually
revealed these problems.
Safety analysts said that these
are of safety significance,
and so some further
investigation should be done.
Then as part of
phase two we decided
we would look at
air traffic that's
of a very different
type from LAX.
And so that's where we
looked at the Denver Airport
because there you have much more
foul weather than what you have
in LA, so we thought
maybe there could
be some new problems
revealed there.
And we also looked at
the New York Metroplex,
so this is primarily the JFK,
LaGuardia and Newark Airport.
And then you sometimes
also get traffic
involving Philadelphia and
Teterboro involved in that.
That, of course, because you
have these multiple airports
with crossing traffic, that's
much more complicated than what
we've looked at so far.
And so there's this
kind of folklore also
that says that if you can
somehow deal with the New York
Metroplex you can deal with
problems anywhere in the world.
So that's why we thought let's
think big and try and tackle
that.
So this is just showing
the full process here
of what goes on
from data collection
to any kind of
analysis that we have.
So at the FAA
level you have data
that's collected
at multiple levels,
so there's, of course,
at the airport level,
and then TRACON and RCC
describe broader levels that
go beyond the airports that
encompass multiple airports.
And so you have data from each
of those representing traffic,
whether it's on route or during
takeoff or landing as well.
Then all of these data
sources are merged together
and result in the PDARS data
that I described before.
One thing that we did not have
within the phase one in LAX,
but we do have in the
phase two at Denver
and The New York Metroplex
is this calculating
of the flight separation.
So in the LA effort we
only look for anomalies
in the shapes of the
trajectories themselves,
without necessarily looking at
whether there are cases where
aircraft were unusually
close together.
We ended up adding that
step for the second phase
and looking at Denver and
the New York Metroplex.
Then this is where we came
in, the NASA portion, where
we took this data
and we actually
separated the data by
runway and by month.
So because, of course, depending
on which runway is chosen,
you're going to have different
trajectories and so that's
why we wanted to look at
each of those separately.
And then we separated by
month looking for anomalies
separately for each
month just to account
for any kind of
seasonal characteristics
that may be present.
Then the main algorithm we ran
is the Multiple Kernel Anomaly
Detection or MKAD
that we developed.
I'll be describing that
a little bit more later.
But essentially, it takes the
trajectories that we enter
and it rank orders them
from most anomalous to least
anomalous.
And so once we get that, then we
do a review with subject matter
experts.
First, our partners
that ATAC, which
is a company near
the San Jose Airport
that we're working with which
has access to PDARS data.
So they have people who are
former air traffic controllers
and generally are
experts in this area.
And they review
these flights going
through more or less
in order from looking
at the anomalous
flights and seeing
is there some kind of
a safety concern there.
And we have, also, once
they vet the flights,
we have shown them to air
traffic controllers who
have generously volunteered
their time to explain what's
going on.
And in some cases we have had
voice recordings available
so then we've been able to
understand what's going on.
But if we have not
had such access,
these controllers have
been able to provide
fairly educated guesses about
what may have been going wrong,
and why the anomalies
that we found
were significant or were not.
So this is another
diagram showing
what we're dealing with here.
So starting with the
TRACON, or, indeed,
any other data sources that
may have been merged with that,
we'll identify a set
of airport arrivals.
And typically whether it's LA,
Denver, or New York Metroplex,
we've had anywhere from
about 100,000 to nearly
400,000 flights
that we've ended up
identifying and
then working with.
So there's the
mining system where
I mentioned that we separated
by runway and by month.
We do also have a
prototype system that
is operating in more of
this morning report style
that I mentioned where it's
looking at flights on a given
day giving an indication
of how anomalous it is
and then providing a
report the next day.
And that's more or less what's
described here where we also
do, like after first
doing some testing then
we'll incorporate
those into training.
And that's what's depicted
here where we then end up
taking some training flights,
separating them by runway,
and running our MKAD
algorithm, getting a model,
identifying anomalies, and then
doing whatever follow-up needs
to be done, whether it's
subject matter expert
review, for example.
So the Multiple Kernel
Anomaly Detection algorithm
is basically a One-Class
Support Vector Machine,
which many of you
may be familiar with.
The upshot of it you
can say is that we
assume that-- I think I
described this a bit earlier.
But the idea is that a
flight, we consider it normal
if it's similar to
most other flights.
Whereas we figure a flight
is probably abnormal
if it's different from
most other flights.
But then the question
is how do you
measure similarity or
difference, in this case.
And so the way we
measure it is really
through this, what's shown here.
So I haven't gone into the setup
of the primal of the One-Class
SVM.
I'm showing here the
dual form because that's,
at least, somewhat
revealing, or as revealing
as equations can be
right after lunchtime.
But what this one shows us,
the vanilla One-Class Support
Vector Machine will have
one kernel function here,
where you could see here I've
shown a kernel function applied
to two data, xi and xj.
In our case, those will
be two trajectories.
So if two trajectories
are very similar-- let's
suppose they're one
on top of the other,
they're the same flight.
Then the kernel
is going to return
or should return a value
of one in that case
to reflect maximum similarity.
Whereas if two trajectories
are very different,
they should return
a much lower value--
one that doesn't
disappear hopefully.
But it should return a
value say close to zero.
And using this
machinery, if you have
a set of flights
that you're checking,
then the similarity between all
pairs of flights is calculated.
And so using that, you can
determine for any flight
how similar it is to
most other flights
to answer the question
of whether it's
normal or anomalous.
Now that works fine if you
have like one modality of data,
but I described the
problems we had earlier
of having data of many
different modalities.
So I described for
a single aircraft
you may have, say,
discretes, discontinuous,
you may have even
safety reports that
are associated with that flight.
How do you put
all those on-- you
can't imagine putting those
on the same coordinate system
and doing, let's say, clustering
and checking for anomalies.
So what we do is here is
have a separate kernel
function for each modality.
And actually, that's kind
of what I describe here.
So for the single
flight, we actually
ran this same algorithm
but with a separate kernel
for discretes, a separate one
for continuous, separate one
for text.
At one point we even tested
incorporating weather data
into this.
But now for this
trajectory problem
we use the same algorithm
but we have different kernels
for latitude,
longitude, altitude,
and distance to the
nearest aircraft.
And the good thing here
is that we can actually
use different kernels
that are appropriate,
depending on the modality here.
So for latitude and longitude
we just use a cosine similarity
kernel, since that ends
up taking into account
the locations and
directions therefore
of the trajectories
that we end up getting.
And then altitude, of course, is
on a very different scale here,
but we still ended up using
cosine similarity for that,
but of course normalize
the data very differently.
For the distance to
the nearest aircraft
we ended up just using
this radial basis function
kernel that's shown here.
And then for the case
where we were looking
at individual aircraft,
we used, of course,
fairly different kernels for
discrete, continuous, and text.
But the key point
is that then rather
than working in your
original data space,
you're mapping all
the different data
with all their
different modalities
into this similarity space,
where for all modalities
you're just getting these
values ranging from 0 to 1.
And then with the
multiple kernel method
you can just measure the
similarity between two data
points by taking their
averages over all
these different modalities.
So for two trajectories
that's exactly what we do.
We take these
measures of similarity
over latitude, longitude,
altitude, and distance
to nearest aircraft,
and just take
a convex combination,
which is depicted here.
We, so far, have
only explored having
equal weights for
all the kernels.
You could, of course,
decide to explore
giving different weights to
different kernels, if you like.
Otherwise though, you still
have the same machinery
as with a One-Class Support
Vector Machine where you end up
with, in this
case-- yeah, I guess
I can probably show it here.
The data points that end up
having these alphas being
positive are what are
called the support vectors.
So some of the benefit
you get, especially when
running the Support Vector
Machine in a testing mode,
is that you don't have to have
all of your training data.
Essentially, the
algorithm figures out
what are called the support
vectors which are the key data
points that you
need to determine
the separator between normal
and anomalous data points.
And so that only those data
points end up being used here.
And instead of a
single kernel you
can still use multiple kernels.
So when, say, a new
flight comes in,
it's compared against all
of your training flights
using this kernel-- it
could be a single kernel,
or in this case
it's a combination
of multiple kernels.
And then that is used to assess
if the data point is an outlier
or is normal, relative
to the training data
the you already have.
And we get also an
indication based
on how strongly
negative or positive
the decision value
that's returned,
you get an indication of how
strongly normal or anomalous
it is.
And so that's where we're
able to get that kind of rank
ordering that I describe, where
then the subject matter expert
is able to go through
the flights in order.
So I'll describe some
results that we got.
So one example that
we found is the case
of a loss of separation,
as it's called.
So in this case,
the aircraft that
ended up being
identified as anomalous
is the one that's
indicated here in orange.
And it ended up
getting relatively
close to another aircraft,
not only in the long space,
but also in terms of
altitude separation here.
And this particular
trajectory ended up
showing up as anomalous because
this orange aircraft was
on descent, and then it suddenly
stopped and actually climbed
a little bit in order
to avoid getting
too close to this
other aircraft,
and then continued on
its descent after that.
So especially the shape of the
trajectory ended up being key.
Yeah, the distance to
the nearest aircraft
also ended up being a factor
in this particular case.
So one thing that we were
told by our domain experts
is that this was in
an air space where
there may have been controllers
handing off the aircraft,
so meaning maybe one
controller was managing it
and then he was supposed to
handoff to another controller
because he reached, say, a
boundary in the air space.
So they hypothesized that
this particular area where
this happened may be a so-called
hot spot where there maybe
are more likely to be
problems because of handoffs
to other controllers.
So this is one where
there was a go-around that
happened due to high speed.
So in this particular
case, the trajectory
that the aircraft
ended up following
was that it came down this
way, he was going too fast--
in this case, over 250 knots at
about 2,500 feet while landing.
He was supposed to land
on this runway here,
but he kind of
overshot this and then
was unable to line up in
time to be able to land here.
So then he decided
to, or it was decided
at you should do a go-around.
Overshot the runway again a
little bit, but not by as much
of a margin, so this
time he was able to land.
So this ended up showing up
as anomalous purely because
of the unusual shape
of the trajectory.
You don't get this kind of
thing happening very often.
So that's where this
ended up being identified.
Another one that we had was what
we call a recurring high speed
vertical descent.
So this was a cargo
aircraft that regularly
lands, in this case, at JFK some
time from 11:00 PM to 1:00 AM.
And there's kind
of this agreement
that this particular aircraft,
being a cargo aircraft
and being at night,
is allowed to take
some creative approaches
to landing so that it
can get closer to the cargo
terminal, so its cargo
facility.
So there is kind of a standard
landing it's supposed to go on,
but the thought is this
is middle of the night,
there are no passengers
who would get frightened.
And so they can allow these
somewhat creative maneuvers
to take place.
And you can see
here on the diagram
the range of different
maneuvers that are taken.
It's quite amusing, unless
you have to fly on it I guess.
So in this case, there's not
really a safety issue here,
but the safety
analyst did point out
that since this is
not really following
the standard operating
procedure, if a new controller
comes online, that person
may not be used to this,
may cause some difficulties
or may raise alarms
where it's not really needed.
So there was the thought that
then maybe procedures like this
should be codified so that
any new controllers that
come online know that
it's OK to do this.
And so in that way, the
anomalies that we find
can be used actually add to
standard operating procedure.
So another one, this
I guess is somewhat--
I shouldn't say
more routine case,
but this happens
every once in a while.
A key job that
controllers have is
to ensure the spacing
between aircraft
that are going to land.
So they have a system
where they identify slots
where aircraft can be plugged
in in order to then land.
And this was a case
where it looked
like there could have been a
potential tie situation, where
two aircraft are trying
to land at the same runway
and there would have
been reduced separation.
And so that, in this case,
this particular aircraft
was told to go around.
And I think this is one where
there's an animation here.
Yeah, this is just
showing the aircraft here.
Not quite sure about the reason
for this little [INAUDIBLE]
here where it gets off
of its approach here.
But then you can see that the
red aircraft gets relatively
close to that other one, and so
then that's where it's told OK,
you probably better go around.
And then eventually, though,
he does go all the way around
here, and then
finally does end up
landing on this
particular runway.
So I should say this is
part of the procedure,
also, that our collaborators
at ATAC follow.
So when we identify
a particular anomaly,
they'll typically pool
up traffic starting
maybe half an hour before just
to see what the whole traffic
situation is, see if there
are any real funny things that
are brewing up in advance of
the anomaly that we identify.
And then they'll make
animations of this sort
to show, let's say, not only
this particular anomaly,
but maybe even other issues
that pop up before that.
And for our work in the
LA area, we were not
able to get access
to voice recordings
because there is a publicly
available archive of voice
recordings, but that
only goes back 45 days,
and we ended up
looking at data that
was about a year back in time.
So that's where we relied
a lot on the educated
guesses of the
controllers to tell us
what may have been happening.
But with our work with
Denver and the New York area,
we've been able to get
access to voice recordings.
So sometimes they're not
present, but once in a
while we're able to get
explanations of anomalies
using the voice recordings.
So this is another
particular anomaly,
what is termed I guess an
aggressive runway change.
So this was the case-- the
anomalous flight, again,
is in orange.
And this is one where the
aircraft was lining up
for approach, but then
there he was going faster
than the aircraft in front here.
And so there was what they call
a potential overtake situation.
And so for that
reason, this aircraft
was told, at least, not to land
here on this particular runway.
The decision ended up
being made to instead
land on this
different runway here.
But the turn that
he ended up taking
was kind of relatively sharp.
And as you probably
know-- I always
hate diagramming
airplanes with my hands.
But when an aircraft is,
say, turning to the right,
it has to bank, so you'll
end up turning like this.
And the same thing happens
with this aircraft.
There was, here, you can see
this aircraft in blue that
was getting ready to
land on a parallel runway
as this particular orange
aircraft was banking
to the right.
And that yields what is
called a belly up situation.
So essentially,
this orange aircraft
was not able to see
this aircraft in blue
while it was landing.
And that's because it's a
quote "belly up" situation--
the aircraft isn't able to see
anything that's at its belly,
so to speak, if you
anthropomorphize the plane.
And that's a situation they
would prefer not to have.
As far as the safety
impact of these data
mining algorithms, what
our collaborators at ATAC
and controllers have
told us is that they
see these anomaly detection
methods, whether it's
MKAD or other methods
that could be used,
can be good to automatically
identify certain safety risks,
and also provide morning
report style feedback
and really identify new
problems that they're not set up
to look for given the current
exceedance-based system.
I mentioned we have
the problem of being
able to highlight certain
problem areas or hot spots,
if anomalies seem to
show up in certain areas,
and that may be indicative
of say issues related
to one controller
handing off to another.
Also, I mentioned about
the idea of the recurring
non-standard operating procedure
maneuvers, these behaviors that
just sort of emerge where
there's really not a safety
issue, but these have
not really been codified,
and our algorithms can help
reveal them and provide
some sort of input
as to actually codify
these different
ways of operating.
We could also use this to
assess whether new procedures
or tools are improving safety.
And that's something
we're actually
getting into now is looking
at operation, say, at a given
airport before and after
some kind of procedure
change to see what the
overall impact on safety
is as a result of that.
See what kind of
anomalies maybe were there
before that are not present
now, and the other way around.
And it can also help to
identify key training examples,
not training examples in the way
that we machine learning types
would think of it, but examples
for training of controllers,
in this case, is what is meant.
So identifying certain
borderline safety situations
that could be good to
train controllers on.
As far as the work that we're
planning, right now when
we run our anomaly
detection algorithms,
domain experts give
some kind of feedback on
whether those anomalies are
operationally significant
or not.
They may give us an
indication of why.
That is not fed back into
the algorithm in any way.
Like the One-Class SVM
runs, but that's it.
There isn't some kind of
feedback that goes into that.
We are looking at augmenting
MKAD with active learning
methods that can be used to
provide this kind of feedback.
Of course, the
difficulty that we have
is that we're looking at not
only the notion of a flight
being anomalous, but then
trying to identify parts
of that flight
that are anomalous,
and oftentimes the
feedback is in that form.
That here's a specific
portion of the flight,
like over these variables or
over these particular ranges
of time that are anomalous.
How can that be incorporated
into an algorithm that's
looking at data at the
flight level really?
But that's something
that we are working on.
I mentioned this prototype
daily reporting system
that we have set up at ATAC.
It still needs to go
through a proper evaluation
over many days, really
seeing what kind
of false positive rate we
have, what kind of new problems
are being revealed.
We would also like to
develop some sort of way
as part of our system to
automatically classify
the known identified events.
So maybe even using the
exceedance-based system
to tag parts of the
flight that we know
are anomalous, or maybe
even based on feedback
the controllers and
other experts have given.
There's also the desire
to automatically link
certain visualization tools.
So I mentioned about how
we use voice, weather,
I showed some of
these animations.
But those are all
operated separately.
So over at ATAC there
are different systems
that are used for all of these.
We would, of course, like to
have a single integrated system
that's able to
pop up an anomaly,
pop up the voice that's
associated with it,
bring up the weather,
automatically bring up
the traffic.
I described about how our
domain experts bring up
the previous half
hour or so of traffic
to see what's been
brewing up in advance.
Bringing that up
automatically would be good.
I guess I described also
the bottom problem there
of studying the airspace before
and after a procedure change.
As far as other work that we do,
we have done anomaly detection
in flight recorded data by
itself, and also jointly
with safety reports.
So there's one carrier with whom
we partner to where they have
allowed us to actually
tie the flight
recorded data with
safety reports.
And so we actually use MKAD to
mine those all at the same time
and look for
anomalies across that.
So that's certainly something
that we'd like to do.
There's the text mining on
the aviation safety reports.
So I described that aviation
safety reporting system.
That only has reports
by itself, not
tied to any flight
recorded data,
but certainly more mining
of that kind of data
would be helpful.
We also really want
to identify precursors
to anomalies in the sense--
most of what I've described here
is really trying to identify
a single anomaly that's
taken place.
What we're really
interested in is
what it was that happened before
that that could have possibly
led to this brewing up.
So why did the one aircraft
nearly overtake the other?
Was he busy doing
something else?
Was he looking at his iPad?
Was he arguing
with his co-pilot?
Some of that we
may never find out
because we don't collect
data, for example,
from within the
cockpit necessarily.
But we may be able
to monitor, say,
the switches that
are being pressed.
We may be able to figure
out that, OK, there's let's
say a rapid sequence
of mode changes
in the auto pilot that may
be indicative of what's
called mode confusion,
where that's a case where
the crew doesn't
really understand what
mode the aircraft is in and
is trying to figure that out.
And of course, that
takes brain cycles,
which may need to be
used for something else.
So that's certainly something
that we'd like to do.
We've done a little bit
of that kind of thing
so far, but certainly
more of that is needed.
We'd really like
to go ultimately
towards identifying a
sequence of steps that went
from, say, a state
that's perfectly normal,
but just happens to be more
likely to lead to some unsavory
state than other ones.
And then see what is
kind of brewing up
until some operationally
significant anomaly actually
takes place.
We do have a facility, it's
called the NASA Earth Exchange.
So that actually ties in
NASA's supercomputing assets
and massive data
storage, together with I
guess you could say kind of a
social networking/collaborative
system that allows, in
this case, earth scientists
to run different analysis,
algorithms on massive data
sets and document them
for reproducibility
and for sharing
with collaborators.
And we had a project funded
competitively by NASA
to implement our data
mining algorithms for use
within the NASA Earth Exchange.
Here I just describe
some of the partners
that we've had in our,
especially on the aviation
safety side, in our work.
So as far as how many
of you can get involved,
we have a system
called DASHlink.
Blue may not be the best font
here, but this is in HTTPS.
Dashlink.ndc.nasa.gov.
It's a collaborative website.
It's for people who are
interested in data mining
and systems health
management primarily.
Any of you can join.
You would need a civil
servant, a NASA civil servant
to approve you.
I would be happy to do that.
Please do mention this
talk as part of that.
And this is a place where you
can set up profiles of your own
describing your research.
You can set up project pages.
You can set up
data sets that you
are allowed to
release to the public,
and you make them available
for others to work with.
We put some of the
data sets that we're
allowed to release on there.
And then our data mining
algorithms, we open source them
and make them
available on DASHlink.
So the MKAD
algorithm I described
is available up there
for people to use.
And we, in fact,
have had carriers
that have gone to this,
downloaded the algorithms
and tried them out on their own.
And we'll help answer
questions within reason.
So this is our team at NASA.
You can see right now,
we're at, what, 10 people,
split about evenly between
researchers and programmers
and support type.
And of course, most of the
work that I described here
is funded by our Aeronautics
Research Mission Directorate,
but we do have certain also
externally funded projects.
The NASA Science
Mission Directorate also
provides funding, but
they do it entirely
on a competitive basis,
whether the people proposing
to do the work are
from NASA or not.
So then that's another way.
The NASA Engineering
and Safety Center
you can think of as
an internal consulting
arm, where if a problem
comes up where they need
some kind of quick
turnaround solution, then
they often go to the NASA
Engineering and Safety Center.
And we have gotten
involved where
it was felt that data
mining could be of help.
So I put my email
address up there
in case you want to
hound me about anything
I've mentioned here.
And this is just some reading,
in case you're interested.
So this first paper
here describes our work
on anomaly detection
for the LAX area,
describing many more anomalies
than what I could have here.
The second paper
describes our work
for the Denver and
New York Metroplex.
This third paper here goes into
the Multiple Kernel Anomaly
Detection algorithm,
and it gives a few
results involving individual
aircraft, the, what's called,
Flight Operations Quality
Assurance or FOQA data.
And then this last one
was one I didn't end up
getting into this work.
But we've developed
an algorithm that's
primarily based on inverse
reinforcement learning
but has a standard reinforcement
learning component to it
as well, that we use for
the problem of identifying
precursors to
particular anomalies.
So what this paper
describes is the case where
you have identified,
I think I described
earlier the high
speed exceedance.
So where during landing
you're going too fast
for the particular altitude.
So with his algorithm we
were able to set that up
as the effect, and
then our algorithm
is able to identify what seemed
to be the precursors to that.
So we end up identifying I
guess what you can consider kind
of an envelope of energy
state, where you can say that
even earlier in the flight,
if you were traveling faster
than a certain speed,
you're probably
kind of beyond some
point of no return,
so to speak, at least given
the data that we have.
So that's just a rather
preliminary test,
but we certainly do plan to
use this to identify precursors
to other particular problems
that, say, a carrier or FAA
or others identify as a problem
they're particularly interested
in, for which they
would really like
to know what the precursors are.
So that I believe is the extent
of what I had planned to say.
I guess I can put that
last slide up and take
any questions.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you Dr. Oza.
For the benefit of
those who are remote,
if you are going
to ask a question
please use this microphone.
AUDIENCE: Can these
detection be used
to detect the drones
when they are going
in the wrong directions,
things like that?
Because I imagine
in the future when
we will have more
and more drones,
there will be accidents.
NIKUNJ OZA: Yeah, I'd
certainly think so.
You would have to have
enough traffic of drones
to where something like
MKAD can get a sense of what
would represent normal
behavior of the drones.
So that you can say that
let's say the drone that's
going in the wrong direction
should be quite atypical
given the data that you have.
But yeah, I think actually
the algorithm as we have it,
with the latitude,
longitude, altitude,
and maybe distance to nearest
aircraft could be relevant.
But yeah, I think so.
Oh, I should add, though, that
we at least so far have not
set it up for real
time monitoring.
So yeah, this is something that
it's really set up right now
to only operate for the
case where, let's say,
flights have already
been completed.
And then after the fact you
are looking for anomalies.
So yeah, for the
real time case I,
think that's
something that we're
thinking of now,
more than before.
Given the way the NASA's
projects are evolving,
I think we're going to be
looking at the real time case
a little bit more in the future.
AUDIENCE: So I'm curious.
For an incident where an
airplane ends up in the Hudson
because some birds affected the
engine, do you filter that out,
or do you actually
include that in as a way
to detect similar anomalies?
NIKUNJ OZA: So we
don't necessarily
eliminate particular
flights right now.
I mean I know that
the data that we get
does not include, say,
military flights or other ones
where they would rather that we
not look into them any further.
But yeah, I think that
the inclusion of flights
that are anomalous shouldn't
really affect us too much.
I guess if a certain flight
occurs too many times
it may start to show up as
normal, given our algorithm.
So that may be of concern.
But something like this,
it should be rare enough
that we'd be able to find it.
AUDIENCE: Its it OK to ask about
this multi-kernel SVM thing?
NIKUNJ OZA: Oh, sure.
AUDIENCE: So the [INAUDIBLE]
combination of kernels--
is it kernel, itself, isn't it?
NIKUNJ OZA: Oh, yes.
AUDIENCE: So for the
sake of understanding,
would it be right to say that
you are looking for a kernel--
well, for a kernel of this
form, which [INAUDIBLE]
margin of algorithm,
something like-- could you
please, if possible,
decouple the kernel
you are looking from
the algorithm itself?
Is it possible to understand
the properties of this kernel
without knowing the SVM itself?
NIKUNJ OZA: Oh yeah.
In fact, yeah.
We are able to develop the
kernels the way they normally
are developed, just making
sure they follow things
like the Mercer's conditions.
In fact, for us-- yeah, one
of the good properties of this
is that we are able to share
the kernels with domain experts
and they're actually
able to understand
that they make sense.
So for example, for the case
of the individual flights where
we have the discrete
and continuous,
just for example
for the discrete,
each flight is just going to
have a sequence of switches,
essentially.
And so the kernel we
use there actually
is the normalized longest
common sub sequence.
So in that case,
like two flights,
let's say they're
exactly the same.
Their common sub
sequence is going
to be the full flight,
right, so that would then
end up normalizing
to a length of one.
Whereas if two flights
are very different,
there's going to be only
a very small part that's
common to them.
And so the length of
that would normalize
to something that's
relatively close to zero.
And so that's
something where we were
able to explain
to domain experts
and they were able to say
that, OK, this make sense.
We did end up adjusting the
values of some of the switches
because some of them were
deemed to not be as relevant.
But then we were just
able to then include that
here as part of the algorithm.
And then when we transitioned
over to the trajectory domain,
we kept the algorithm
exactly the same,
except just swapped out kernels.
AUDIENCE: I might have
a follow-up question.
Is there any problems you
know of with this approach,
like maybe an
algorithm attempting
to prefer some kernels over the
others or something like that?
NIKUNJ OZA: Yeah, actually.
Yeah.
I mean certainly
that can be an issue.
I mean one issue that we haven't
dealt with at all, really,
is the case where you just
have these separate kernels
and what kind of weight
are you giving to them.
So should the text
kernel, for example,
have the same weight as the
discrete and the continuous?
Not really sure.
And then I guess
another issue also
that we kind of have noticed is
that for the continuous kernel,
the way we actually do
it is that we take all
of the different variables,
however many they were.
I don't think we've
ever used more
than 20 continuous
variables at once.
But what we actually
do is discretize
each of them using a Symbolic
Aggregate approXimation,
the SAX approximation that
Eamonn Keogh and his colleagues
developed.
It's a way of just discretizing
all the different variables.
And then we actually
put all of those
into a single discrete sequence
corresponding to the times
when each variable has a
change from one discrete bin
to another.
So we know the times at
which each variable has
a change in the
discretized version.
Note the time at which
it happened, and we
put those changes in order
into a single sequence.
Now, the problem
then with that is
that you're taking so many of
these continuous variables,
putting them into a
single sequence that
has a weight of like
one-third or one-quarter.
Now, there may be significant
changes in one or two
of the variables that are
kind of getting washed out
in the process of doing
this combination with so
many other variables.
That's admittedly something
we still have to resolve.
Is that along the lines
of what you're mentioning?
I'm sorry if I'm--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And may I ask the last question?
Sorry.
So I heard that sometimes when
you try to discover anomalies,
you have a lot of normal cases
and only a few anomalies,
and that throws
the algorithm off.
So do you have such problems?
And if you do, then how
do you deal with them?
NIKUNJ OZA: So we haven't had a
huge problem with them so far.
I guess maybe the
biggest problem we've had
is that for the case of say
the flight recorded data,
there tend to be a fair
number of go-arounds.
So we tend to get a
large number of them.
And they are of
varying interest.
Some of them are
just routine ones
where they say, OK, it's
not really a big deal.
Some of them are
of concern not so
much for the go-around
itself, but maybe
what prompted the go-around.
So I showed examples of things
like the potential overtake
situation.
So the problem is not so much
the go-around but the overtake.
But sometimes go-arounds seem
to happen for certain, whatever
other reason and
there doesn't seem
to be a concrete
precursor to that
and it's not that big a deal.
That, overall, is probably
the biggest issue we faced.
Also, with the
trajectory anomalies,
we haven't really had the case
where a flight was identified
as, let's say, abnormal
that turned out
to be like perfectly normal.
But sometimes those are
not of safety concerns,
because let's say it's
maybe an unusual trajectory
but it happens at night.
So there aren't too many
other aircraft around
so it's not such a big deal.
Or I described the problem
of the cargo aircraft
where passenger comfort
is not really an issue.
So in that case trajectory
anomalies are OK.
We have had cases,
actually, though
with unusual trajectories
where it turned out instead
of a commercial aircraft,
it was a regional jet.
And the regional
jets being smaller
are much more maneuverable.
So I guess that's one case
where something that's normal
pops up as an anomaly for us.
We've had a few of those.
But overall, it hasn't
been a big problem.
AUDIENCE: So most of the
examples that you showed
were of anomalies that were
sort of detected in real time
by the controllers or were of
no concern to the controllers.
Did you find any that were not
detected and perhaps should
have been?
NIKUNJ OZA: So actually, yeah.
So actually, for the
ones that I showed,
they were ones where
safety analysts did
say that it should go
through some further review
where they had not
originally planned to.
So as you said, they
were likely things
where during the
operation, yes, controller
realizes OK something
was happening,
and let's say a go-around
should be issued.
But they didn't decide to
put it through some kind
of further safety review.
And it was after
our algorithm was
run that they decided
that it should
go through some further
review at least.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, thank you very
much, Dr. Oza, and thank you.